this is sort of a strange way to start
the first show with me back in studio
I've been away for a couple days we have
we've had Ferren cousins from Ring of
Fire filling in for me weird topic weird
way to start but we we really do need to
talk about whether you and I'm talking
to you in the audience whether you want
me to address something vile and
something that is really quite depraved
and that is the so-called crisis actor
false flag conspiracy theories and if
you don't even know what that is good I
wish I were in your shoes I wish I
didn't know what it was either
but what it is is that very often when
there's a mass shooting there are these
elements from the underbelly of the
internet and from the Alex Jones Show
that claim that the events were staged
with actors and there's always some
motive that they come up with so if it's
a Democratic president that's in the
White House then the reason that one
would stage a false flag attack using
crisis actors would be as a pretext to
take guns away from people and of course
never happened under President Obama as
you probably know if it's a Republican
president in the Oval Office then the
reason is to make the president look bad
you're staging one of these incidents to
make the president look bad maybe also
to justify taking guns away and they'll
attempt to prove this by pointing out
that it's all the same so-called actors
that appear as victims in the shootings
you see them on TV you see them being
interviewed even in different parts of
the country it'll be the exact same
people that are the victims in a
California shooting and then the same
kid shows up as a victim in the Florida
shooting for example and then the other
angle is there was a military or
terrorism drill scheduled to take place
on the same day and that's part of the
conspiracy it's stuff like that right
now in the past I've sometimes done
these 20 minute videos going piece by
piece through the conspiracy theory and
debunking each element of it and some
people appreciate it but then others
would just watch it and come up
with new claims about how will I ignored
this detail or that detail is actually
part of the conspiracy
there was really no changing of minds
right people who agreed with me that
there was no such conspiracy already
didn't believe it so the video didn't
make a difference and then the people
who believed in the conspiracy theory
weren't going to have their minds
changed by me doing a video so at a core
level first of all think about how
absurd the idea is right whatever entity
pulled off the successful orchestration
of mass murder as well as presumably the
brainwashing of a shooter to get them to
do it wasn't able to hire a company that
had more than the same few dozen actors
to play the victims right I mean it's
absurd at its face how incompetent are
the same people that can pull off the
incredible conspiracy of actually
getting the shooting to happen so my
instinct Pat is maybe just ignore this
stuff because there's it's there's just
such cognitive dissonance among the
believers that I don't know that the
debunking is really gonna do anything
it's very hard to go up against them and
often doesn't bear any fruit because any
evidence that you present that is
supposed to debunk the conspiracy theory
is interpreted as evidence that supports
the conspirators exactly so we take
these Parkland School victims maybe
people will say that oh you have the the
yearbook so there are academic records
well that just goes to show that they
were planning this for a long time
that's exactly right they were willing
to Photoshop and do whatever they could
exactly and it you will only get a
stronger belief in the conspiracy and so
you might I mean everything Pat and I
have said so far would suggest don't
don't even talk about it don't don't
debunk it don't try to do anything the
logical question is well David then why
are you even asking us isn't it obvious
that you should just ignore it the only
thing that makes me wonder whether it is
worth commenting on it would be to try
to more broadly discredit the types that
will push this stuff every single time
right it's sort of the idea that if
people realize that Alex Jones is
pushing an absurd narrative about child
actors for crisis actors and false
flags then maybe we should look at his
claims about Trump and guns and the
economy with a skeptical eye and of
course strictly speaking right every
assertion needs to be evaluated on its
own otherwise it's a sort of ad hominem
fallacy to say because a person a was
wrong about one thing they are by
definition wrong about everything else
but no matter whether or not they're
right on some issues I wouldn't want to
be getting my news from someone who
thinks the shooting in Florida last week
was anything other than a tragedy
connected to gun culture firearms
availability and mental health not a
staged operation akin to a Hollywood
movie that's the one thing that makes me
think maybe there is some value in
exposing this stuff I don't know the
answer I think the other factor there is
how many people believe the conspiracy
theory yeah like if it's something
that's very fringe and just a few folks
are buying into it maybe that's not
worth it for us but something like 9/11
being a hoax a significant chunk of
Americans at one point believe yes
although the counter to that would be
when it's the ones that more people
believe the impact of one debunking may
not really make that big of a dent in
the number of believers there's a part I
guess yeah there's an argument to be
made either way so listen send me your
thoughts let me know what you think we
should be doing about this type of thing
ignore it altogether mention it exists
but don't get into the details because
getting into the details won't really
convince convince anyone or really dig
into it the way we've done with some of
these in the past like the Sandy Hook
shootings I don't know the answer I'm
waiting to hear from you and I guess
we'll develop some kind of policy and
maybe the policy would be decide on a
case-by-case basis I don't know the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership